Jubilee was always herself on The
Bachelor today I could be very socially
awkward and it didn't really work out
for her then sent her home but would she
return to reality TV everybody has
talked about how it would be great to
see a black woman be a Bachelorette the
Bachelorette would you ever take on that
role um I don't think anyone would turn
down that role um obviously there's a
lot to think about
being in that position and playing that
role I call it um but I think it's a
once-in-a-lifetime chance and since I
already know that the process works I
don't think it's something I would turn
down I definitely want to find my
somebody yeah
well Ben clearly said he's found his
somebody uh you said a couple times that
you felt dumped by him which is a pretty
strong word dumped yeah I mean I don't
know what else to call it
you nicely left the in Mexico she
definitely speaks her mind and I had to
get her opinion on this week's Bachelor
controversy well what was your reaction
to finding out that he said I love you
to two women which is definitely gonna
get a lot of fans talking um I felt for
the person that he didn't pick ya really
badly and that was my first reaction
like that's that's tough
so my automatic reaction was oh my god
what happens to the girl who doesn't you
know when you just gave her so much
validation and you basically made her in
her mind think that she was getting that
ring because people don't say on the
show that I love you Ben kind of broke
the rules as they call it so my
automatic reaction was oh my goodness
like that's got to hurt for the person
you know they're gonna be blindsided
automatically that's unheard of whose
team if you had to pick are you on
Lauren B Jojo I am team Jojo Jojo is a
lot of fun and she is a sweetheart and
she's a great person she is a great
person I'm team Jojo
all the way